Beyond the model, you need a pseudocode
notation for formalizing algorithms.
So let's start with our traditional
sequential pseudocode notation and
let's make the following changes.
First we'll write our algorithms
assuming a single-program,
multiple data style.
HPC nerds refer to this as S-P-M-D or
SPMD style.
The way SPMD works is as follows.
First, you'll write some
pseudocode algorithm.
Then you'll imagine running
that algorithm on some cluster,
and you'll assume that that pseudocode
is replicated on all the nodes.
We'll call every running copy a process.
Each process runs independently and
asynchronously from the others
in the absence of barriers or any other
kind of explicit synchronization.
Now, to distinguish the copies
from one another, we'll assume
that the pseudocode algorithm has
access to two global variables.
One called RANK and one called P.
Since the memories are private,
these variables are private
to each running process.
RANK will be the ID of the running
process and it'll be unique.
P will be the number of processes.
Now for the moment,
the concept of a process and
the concept of a node
are basically interchangeable.
But in practice, a process
virtualizes the concept of a node.
That means you might have more than
one process assigned to a node if, for
example, you're running on
a multi-socket, multi-core system.
Now, to see how this works, suppose
that this pseudocode algorithm contains
a line of code which reads as follows.
So when all the processes run,
they'll all print statements
of the following form.
I am 0 out of 5,
I'm 1 out of 5, and so on.
They each print their own rank and
the total.
Here's a second change to
a sequential pseudocode.
I will give you a primitive which
performs an asynchronous send.
Think of it as an API call
that looks like this.
Now it has two arguments,
one is a buffer of size n.
The second is a destination rank,
basically the rank of the process that's
supposed to receive this message.
Now, an important and
subtle point about sendAsync is
what does it mean when it returns?
When it returns, it does not mean
that the buffer has been sent.
It just means that a send is
registered with the system.
So in particular, until you know what's
happened you should not modify buf.
To find out what happened,
sendAsync will return a handle.
You can do some testing on the handle.
Now, for
this send to eventually complete,
the destination rank has to
post an asynchronous receive.
The signature looks the same.
It names buffer of some size, and
it names a source rank,
source being the sender.
Just like sendAsync,
when recvAsync returns,
it does not mean the data is available.
Rather, recvAsync will
return a handle and
you should do some
testing on the handle.
This business about handles brings
us to the final primitive which is
called wait.
In particular, wait is a blocking
operation that takes one or
more handles as arguments.
Now, wait will pause until
the corresponding operations complete.
Now there's also a special form
of wait called a wait all,
abbreviated here by
wait with an asterisk.
This is a shorthand that says wait for
all outstanding sends and receives so
that we don't have to track and
check all the handles all the time.